so
for the for most of our previous
communication of react we talked about
big ideas like the virtual dom
re-rendering the entire application on
every single update
or
don't use template use javascript and in
this talk i'm not going to cover those
but i'm going to talk about all the
small details
about the api of react that makes it
scale to facebook
engineering so right now we have more
than we have
many thousands react component inside of
facebook and we're really committed to
it
and
this requires some
things you know to make it scale
and so the
best
way
to make the product the developers more
productive using react has been to
minimize the time to find the root cause
of a bug
so ideally we would like to reduce the
number of bugs in our system
and so we can do that
one by not making any more bugs but this
is really hard to do and the second one
is to
make fixing bugs a lot easier so this is
what we've been trying to do is react
and the way to do that
is
first you need to understand how
a bug is being
fixed
so for example in this case
we have a to-do mvc with one element
but
it says two items left so there's
obviously a bug
so as a developer you're first
going to try to reproduce the bug and
put your application in that state
and then you're going to want to find
the code that was being used to generate
this number two
and so as a web engineer you're going to
right click inspect element and you're
going to see that
and so now at this point you're going to
find something that's unique
for example the string to do count
and you're going to grip on your entire
code base
and you're going to look for to-do count
and you're going to find all the matches
and try to guess
which one
is
used to generate it
and so it usually works pretty well but
it's a bit of a hit and miss process
and sometimes like you're going to use a
component that's
being used like all over the place and
you're going to have to dig more and you
need an intimate
understanding of the code base that
you're looking at in order to debug
so in order to make this part easier we
introduced the react dev tools
so if you install this little chrome
extension
then you can
click on the react tab
and it's going to
give you the react
virtual dom node that was being used to
generate this element
and so in this case you're going to see
to do footer
and the interesting thing with this is
at facebook
we uniquely name all our react
components
and so you can look for the file to do
footer.js to find where the code is
being executed
and we've got some nice things as well
which is the props and states of your
component are available on the right and
they're live editable so you can change
the count completed count and it's going
to live updates
so now we found the file that was being
used
and
this variable count
is the one that
value
is two and we want it to be one
and so now when i ask people how do you
debug this like oh what's up your
process they're going to say oh i'm
going to use a debugger
and i often look at them look over the
shoulder and i'm like yeah you're not
doing it right like you're lost and it's
not working and there are two
fundamental
issues because
with that
so the first one is the debugger is
forward in time so you set a breakpoint
somewhere and you go next
whereas as a developer
what you want to do is to find
the places where this variable has been
updated in the past
and so you want to go backward
and the second one is the debugger
you're going to execute like every
single line so you can you have some
control you can skip over function but
like it's really limited and if somehow
you screw up and you press run one more
time like you have to repeat the process
like from the start and it's very
annoying
whereas at the developer
you would like to be able to go back
only where this count variable has been
updated
and then
and if it has been updated multiple time
you're going to go back and back and
back
and you can put a console.log and rerun
and see if this variable has a right
value and once you see
once you isolate where the probability
code is
then you can do your things and fix the
bug
and so now
that we understand the process we need
to be able to actually
make it faster
so the first type of variable the count
can be
is local variable
and local variables are easy to debug
because they are scoped to a function
and most of the time functions
are really small like less one than 100
lines
and so you can just scroll up as a
developer and you're going to see why
it's not working and why the assignment
is not good
so
at the extreme opposite is the state of
your application
and if you don't do anything
on your code base to structure it
correctly
the variable can be updated like from
anywhere like your state can be
updated from anywhere and any file in
your system and this makes it very very
hard to to go back one step
so with react
what we've done is
we scoped
the state to a component a react
component
this means that if a state variable of
the real component doesn't have the
right value you only have to look inside
of this component to see why it was
broken so but
one file
is still quite big
and we
with react we added another
constraint which is that the only ways
to modify the states is via two
functions get initial state and set
state
and because we added those constraints
you can just control f on the file and
look for set state and you're going to
find all the places where the state has
been updated
and this in a couple of seconds
so we reduced
the search space from the entire code
base
to
a couple of lines in your file
and the second
type
of variable in a react application is
props
so props are values that are being
passed from your parents and one of the
great property of props is that they are
immutable so you should never update
your props this means that if the
value of your prop is not correct
you just have to look for your parents
for the call site
that was being used
but still the call sites
if your component
is only being used once or twice
then it's going to be easy but if it's a
core component
then you're going to have a lot of call
sites
and
one of the trade-offs
of passing
uh things uh program uh declare like of
passing things
and specifying it is that it's quite
variables for example if you want to
pass an element from a grandparent or a
grand grandparent to a child
then you need all the
elements in the between to know about it
and we look around and there's actually
a solution that for this which is for
example in angular
the scope
all the
values are inherited from your parent
and your grandparents and your
grandparents so this has a good effect
of reducing the number of code that you
have to write
but it also has a very bad effect
which is that if a props
is doesn't have the right value
so now you not only have to check all
the call sites but now all of their call
sites and all of their whole sites and
all of their call sites and at this
point you're basically lost
you have to search like a large part of
your code base and it's really hard to
track bugs
and as a co valerie
it's also hard for someone to change
a value at at a very root level because
you've got no idea whose
children and grandchildren and grand
grandchildren are going to be affected
so in order to write your you
in order to test if you didn't break
anything
like you're going to have to check a lot
of files and usually you're not going to
and you're going to introduce bugs
so we decided not to introduce this
feature
and instead having a lot having a bit
more boilerplate
and
again if you're in a
developer tools
you can just press up and you're going
to see which parent component has been
called so if you're in the in this setup
you can know instantly the call sites
so it's again shortening the
step
so this is for props and states and we
also introduced something that's very
unique among javascript libraries which
is that you can type
your
props
and for example in this case
the count
value
is a number and is required and active
to the world is a string
and we're going at runtime to check
those types
and in order to understand why it's
useful
i'm going to
step back
and look at languages in general
so we've got basically like two main
families static languages
and dynamic languages
and if you see the evolution of static
languages
they're trying to
make you write less types
for example in c plus plus they recently
introduced the auto keyword
which lets the compiler infer the type
of the variable for you so you have to
write it
and now if you look at dynamic languages
for example javascript and php
since you don't write any type by
default we want to write more types
and for example javascript introduced
typescript and php
uh introduced hack in order to do that
and the comment
the and they both converge into what i
call a sweet spot
which is that you want types and
function arguments and you want all
everything else
being untyped being inferred by the
compiler or by whatever
and there are two reasons for that
sorry
and the interesting thing is that you
could you can compare
a function to a component so if you
think about a real component it's like a
function that takes properties
and that returns a virtual dom
and so in that in this case it makes
sense
to type component props
like languages type function arguments
and there are two main reasons to that
the first one is all about documentation
because
the interface of your component is typed
this means that you can as a developer
just look at this file
and you're going to see all the type all
the attributes that it that are required
and you can call this component with
those
and the second one is that
it prevents the propagation of errors
so for example if you have a bad
variable in one component
and you pass it to another component and
that passes it to another component and
modifies it a bit
in javascript
it's rarely going to throw and so this
bad value can like propagate
very far
and at one point is going to throw
and it's going to be really hard because
it's going to take a lot of ups in order
to go back
to the initial
issue
and so if you have x
and so if you have prop types then
you're going to stop the propagation of
those exceptions
exactly when the parent calls a child so
you know directly
whenever is going to be
whenever the problem is happening and
you don't have to do the ops
and
so all of those
like it's it's really intuitive to
if we have your if your goal
is to reduce
the time it takes to trace back
where the variables get set it's very
intuitive to do the steps that we've
done
but someone on twitter asked me
i don't like jsx and i don't like the
way the react dom
is constructed and i want to use jquery
instead
and we've had great success
from from the coffeescript community and
the closurescript community in coming up
with new dsls to write them elements so
it's not
so
why not using jquery
but in this case there's a fundamental
issue with
is that
you never know when a component using
the jquery way of doing it
is completed
and so at any point in time
someone can add an attribute to that
component
and what this means is
someone can for example in this case
override the id element
and at any point in time
and it's very
bad for when you're developing code
because now anytime you have a function
call in your code that passes the
element
now you have no idea if the function
call is going or not to mute the element
and so if you want to know whether it's
mutated or not then you've got to
inspect that function and all the
function tree that is using this element
and we've g we've had in the past a lot
of bugs because of this
because someone deep in the call stack
like this modifies the element and it's
really hard to understand why
but at the same time
once an element is formed
it's very useful in occasions to be able
to modify it
and we need to find a way to do it
in a safer way
and for this we introduced
the api clone with props
and clone with props takes an element
and it takes new props like new
attributes and it's going instead of
modifying the element
it's going to create a new element
with all the modify properties and
you're going to assign it to a variable
and the very interesting fact with this
is that now you
any call site that wants to modify this
element is going to return the modified
element
and so you only
have to look at this specific call site
pattern
if you want to see if
an element has been modified or not
and so since this pattern is usually
the exception like you trim down a lot
of potential source of bugs in your
application
and
one of the one other idea about this is
for props and with this we're using
immutable objects
and you might think that immutable
objects you can only get benefits from
them using
haskell or lisp
but in fact you can also use the
benefits in javascript
if you impose that you can modify
objects and they have really really good
properties
in order to debug
elements
so in order to conclude
at facebook we have a motto which is
move fast and break things
and what it really means is it's okay to
break things
but
once you discover that
something is broken you want to fix it
as fast as possible
and especially you want to fix it before
it goes support
and in order to do that we want our
application
we want to be able to fix bugs
in a very fast way
but we don't know how to do it fast so
what we want to do is to be predictable
and when fixing a bug there are two main
sources of in predictability
so the first one is finding the root
cause so you've got a repro case
and how do you find what was an issue
and so with all the steps i i described
we can make this a lot faster
and the second one is
and so once you know the root cause
then you want to be able to find a fix
and this part is not usually the hardest
part
like all the interviews and all the
school like
you're an engineer to so you can
get a problem
and your form to find a solution so we
are pretty good at doing this
but then the second impressibility is
what if your fix is going to
introduce another bug
and so this is a really bad moment for
example if something is severely broken
in production and you want to like fix
it fix it as soon as possible and then
you come like you launch a fix and then
it triggers something else another bug
and then it triggers another bug and
then you've got to like figure out
another solution
and it turns out that
by making
finding the root cause
faster and easier
you're also making your application
easier to read
and also so if you're you're doing a
modification to a variable it's really
easy for you to trace back
how this variable is being used
and therefore it's also harder to
introduce bugs
by modifying this variable without you
knowing about it
so this is what i have i hope it was
useful thanks
so
do
you